(exciting rock music)
- My name is Fortune Feimster,
I am originally from a tiny town
in North Carolina
called Belmont.
I didn't start comedy
in North Carolina,
I started when I
got to Los Angeles.
Because I figured, why not start
where it's really difficult.
I actually started in
sketch comedy and improv
at the Groundlings.
Somebody came to one
of my improv shows
and was like, you're a stand-up,
why are you not doing stand-up?
I don't know if it's
'cause I look weird,
or if they're like, oh, you're
not going to do anything else
in life, so you might
as well tell jokes.
I'm just really happy
that I made it here.
I was almost late
catching my plane
'cause I was teaching
a yoga class.
He's like, that did not happen.
You're right, I did
not teach a yoga class.
I went to one, obviously,
look at this, boom!
Ah?
He's checkin' out my yoga booty.
It was pretty awesome though
because the yoga teacher,
she let me do the modified
version of everything.
So like, the class
would do downward dog
and she'd let eat raviolis.
I didn't know that I was gay,
and so when I was at college,
my mom, she'd call me up
and say, I don't understand
why you get so upset
when your friend Michelle
goes out on dates with guys.
And I was like, because
she's my best friend!
And I'm like, super
intense about it.
And it's the most real joke
that I think that I have
because it stems from
years of just not knowing,
legitimately not
knowing that I was gay
and being so weirdly intense
about my friends that I secretly
kind of had this crush on.
And she really just
did not get it,
and I was just like,
you don't know!
We're so close!
And everybody else
was like, duh.
When I told my mom I
was gay, she was like,
really, what do you mean?
I'm like, what do you mean?
I'm like, look at me.
Now my mom's way supportive,
not that she wasn't supportive
of me being gay then,
but now she's like
overkill, like,
she's the president of
PFLAG, it's this organization
of parents of lesbians and gays,
and she's like everyday posting
on Facebook about gay rights
so I have to be the
one that's like, mom,
you need to, can you
just tone it down?
My mom's a bit of a lightweight.
It takes her one whiskey sour,
and then she's
completely toasted.
She's like, yeah,
that's my style,
I wanna hang out with your mom.
You can always tell
when my mom's tipsy
because she'll stick
one finger out,
just like this, and start
dancing just like this.
Just judging people
while she's dancing.
(exciting rock music)